are you a natural-born writer I don't
know what a natural-born writer is I
felt like I wanted to write for a long
time when I was in maybe even in middle
school and then and then high school I
didn't know if I couldn't be writer but
I my first inkling that I had talent as
a writer was I went to a summer school
at Andover Academy in Massachusetts I
was a public school kid all the way but
my parents sent me to this fancy private
school for a summer program and
everybody had to take English
Composition classes so the teacher of my
particular English English Composition
class had us write our own poetry and
stories and this guy said you know you
you're a writer and you should keep
doing this and I just listened to that
and little by little it started to come
out did you go home that day and
proclaim to your parents no no okay no
it was like 1969 and I was more
interested in going to Woodstock and
doing things like that Abbie Hoffman
things like no girls all right okay
forget about the protest yeah what is
better the burning desire to create or
the burning desire to be a star
co-create burning desire to create is
the for me the the concept of being a
star just to hear you say that it just
it just makes me ill I mean if you
become a star how that's great that's
great but when you for me personally I
mean I know maybe for an actor they have
that burning desire to be a star and it
makes them a star and it makes them do
their best work but for me it always
starts with the work so the burning
desire to create but also the burning
desire to create something worthy
not just anything something that you can
at the end of the day say yeah that's
that's good well I was going to your
website is you have a new book out so
doing research for your your new book
which just you just just came out it's
called the way we worked oh nice
look on the job in Hollywood and it's
taeil's from TV right tales not only
from TV writers it started out as a book
that would be about TV writers telling
their stories because when you run
writers rooms when you work in writers
rooms and I did this for over 20 years
every single writer has many stories to
tell about development hell production l
casting hell there are so many kinds of
L's
that writers have to deal with and that
getting those stories and archiving them
was the original motivation for this
book and then it got beyond writers i
wanted to include people from every job
in the business so there's
above-the-line people there's
below-the-line people and it's a really
comprehensive overview of what it's like
to work in Hollywood we have a quote
from Robert Towne that you that you put
with a little picture it just said
something like the writers is the one
that until they finish what they do know
sort of they're the bleep a hole that
you know until they finish what they do
no one else has a job no one else has a
job that's right so he you know towns
point of view as he states in the book
is that everybody you know is waiting
for the writer to get his work done you
know so they can they can be higher than
they could have a job so and what's more
than that that's another way of saying
and this is no secret everybody knows
this that it all starts with the script
if you don't have a script
not only can nobody be hired but yeah
you can't you have no work you can't
shoot anything and it's also very
important to have a good script the best
you can offer these actors and directors
because
you know anybody can put words on paper
but to make them sing and to make a
piece of work that's original obviously
requires a lot of work well that being
said so people are waiting for the
writer to finish their work but then
once the works finish the writer can
sometimes be the least important
unfortunately in the eyes of the
production so in in film this has been
the case since Hollywood began that the
writer was totally dispensable this is
why these famous novelists came out like
Raymond Chandler whoever they came out
to Hollywood to work in the movies to
make some money but their scripts were
you know rewritten by other people and
when it was all over it was
unrecognizable to them and they just
went back to writing novels because that
was really their work and that has been
magnified times a hundred today so you
know you'll see maybe six credited
writers on a finished screenplay and
there will have been 20 writers actually
hired because the only ones who get the
credits are the ones who there's an
arbitration now for every film that has
multiple writers so the writers guild
arbitrates every single feature film and
they're and they read all 20 drafts
written by all 20 writers and they
decide which of those 20 writers will
get credit it could be two writers if
there's 20 writers it's going to be at
least two that get credit it could be
two it could be six it'll never be 20
because they have the limit of how many
that you can credit but that's life in
feature film writing TV is different TV
is different and up until not that long
ago the writer was King and if you were
a writer
creator executive producer you had a
whole lot of power and people went to
you as the go-to voice of the show now
we have so many layers on
top of the writers people who do nothing
now there are some executives that are
helpful and involved but there's so many
layers now built into the process I'll
give you an example you want to do a
show with an actor an actor has managers
it has three managers there is a
production company that the actor may
have a deal with and then there's a
studio and then there's the network so
all of these people the managers get
credit as producers they get credit not
only they get credit as producers they
get a per show episodic fee for doing
what for being the manager of the star
and then there is a production company
maybe their production company and
they'll take a a chunk and then the
studio will take a chunk and then the
network and I left out one other entity
that takes a chunk and it's the source
of what's going on in Hollywood today
and that is the big agencies and their
packaging fees and that's what this
whole writers versus agents battle is
about right now that the agencies take
these huge chunks of the budget for
themselves so the show budgets are lower
and writers can't afford to hire some of
the writers they may want because the
agencies are keeping the budgets lower
so they can take their their chunk so
that's my pitch for the writers he
mentioned Raymond Chandler in the last
segment and he's an interesting guy in
the sense that he actually left a
lucrative career or he was pushed out of
one to go further enjoys writing but for
most writers whether they're TV writers
film writers novelists what sacrifices
do you think one has to make to have a
career in art and I realize that's a
broad term in art in Orion huh well
let's say your career is art and art is
really what you care about if you're
novelist you pretty much have to get
another job because until that moment
and there's very few people who can do
this I write novels now after having a
you know a pretty successful career in
television writing so I'm not counting
on that for my income the people who can
make big money writing novels are the
kind of writers who can create a
detective character and run that
character through many many and through
a series of books and crank them out
fast and you can make a living that way
so but still you have to get to that
point and you have to have another job
until you get to that point as a writer
for television let's say that is your
art you have to have a number of sample
scripts that people are going to like
pilots these days is what they want to
see original pilots and it's so
competitive today that a lot of people
are going out and shooting in YouTube's
of what you know maybe a ten minute
segment of what their idea is and
anything you can do to sort of
distinguish yourself is important and
you know you have to look at your bank
account you have to look at the way you
want to live and just really what I
would say is you decide what what
lifestyle you can live in until you you
get to where you want to be and also
speaking personally I think you have to
come up with a plan B one of the
actresses I interview in this book you
know when I one of the questions I asked
all the people I interviewed is what
what your advice to people who want to
do what you do and this one woman who's
one of the most talented actresses I
know told people to do something else
full-time and do this you know in
Community Theatre into it for fun
because it's gotten too hard and this
woman was on Broadway in lay miserable
you know she's really really talented so
you know I would say and then a plan B
is important and even if you wind up
working a job you hate
carve out those hours to do what you
love
well I mean Dashiell Hammett when you
talk about detective not work he was a
private investigator and then oh yeah
it's interesting when you look at the
two careers of Raymond Chandler versus
Dashiell Hammett didn't work
Dashiell Hammett wasn't as financially
successful in the end was that right
then I'm not sure then Raymond Chandler
yeah that's true
oh wait could you do you mind holding up
your book it's a beautiful color it is
it's called the way we work on the job
in Hollywood and yeah and somebody
pointed out that they were really glad
that the cover is in all beauty and palm
trees it's more grit and the valley it's
the valley it's where it happens and
it's not glamorous as it happens sure
it's only glamorous if you get to the
head level and get to go to the parties
afterward well even Raymond Chandler and
his his you know talking about 1930s LA
and all the corruption and and crime and
it wasn't glamorous then in the sense of
some of the stuff that was happening the
underbelly of the town and I think in
not just the the crime and some of the
scandals but in terms of the day to day
grind if you have a job and you have to
get to it and it's a pain to get to
wherever you need to go yes I've got a
factor in so much and find parking and
it's it's it is and you know speaking to
the writers when I got into this there
were far fewer people doing it so I had
a much easier time getting people to
read my material I if I wrote a decent
spec script I gave it to a friend of
mine who was on a show and suddenly it
would be on the desks of really
important people and they would call me
in for a meeting I mean it's much harder
today so you really have to do whatever
you can do to kind of distinguish
yourself use every contact you know and
you know for some of the writers that
that I know and actors they're not there
they do everything so they're doing
improv they're doing voiceover their
writing and their editing and they're
just trying to scrape together a life
and you know if you're willing to do
that that's one way to go until one
thing pops when I was coming up
you concentrated on one thing you
learned how to do it really really well
and that was your thing and I would
assume that I had when I was coming up
some sort of time period in my head and
probably didn't actually for how long I
would it would take before I would do it
before I you know would say hey I got a
bag this and think about how I can you
know get a job and his benefits or
something like that but back then nobody
had a plan or anything I think you
really need a plan today to you know
figure it out looking at your IMDB you
have envía bul credits I watched a lot
of those shows growing up there was a
bosom buddies facts of life all that I
spent a lot of time from the TV so I
just you know it was it was sort of my
babysitter at times and I love those
shows but you're not in the TV world as
much you stay I'm a little dipping my
toe in I mean I'm at this point in life
where if I can get to do what I want to
do I'm happy to jump back into TV but
it's harder and harder to do that when
you've been out of it for a while and so
what I'm doing is I have this my first
novel elevating Overman Jason Alexander
did the audiobook for me he wants to do
this for Netflix or whomever and so you
know we have we're trying to pitch that
around and if people want to do that
great if people want to do something
else with me that I want to do that's
great
but I'm not going to go work as a hired
gun on some show that I don't believe in
or you know you know when you get to
this point it's all about the quality of
the work so if somebody said hey Bruce
you know we're gonna do what we're gonna
go back and reboot Breaking Bad and do
another season and we'd like you to work
on it that would be awesome because
Breaking Bad is an awesome show but if
it's stuff that I don't really relate to
I don't need to do it so I don't want to
do it I'd rather go and you know
continue writing my books that being
said for someone just starting out
what's your advice to them if they know
that taking something maybe they don't
totally believe in it could be it's not
violent or sexist or politically wrong
in their views but they just don't feel
the materials that great but they need
it as a stepping stone do it absolutely
I took the worst jobs ever when I
started and I write about that in this
book the kind of shows that I had to
work on you know and they were awful
some of them I worked in this show
called Webster being a writer who wanted
to work on Cheers
and being offered the job they offer you
is Webster so we always felt like
third-class citizens can you take us to
the first day as the showrunner for home
improvement what was that like how are
you interacting with the writers
well I knew all the writers I had either
work with them in previous years or had
hired them myself and chances are if I
hired them myself I had worked with them
maybe on other shows so that was all
easygoing but you know home improvement
was like a juggernaut it was a huge show
and it was a huge responsibility to be
the showrunner and it was my first job
as a showrunner once I found out that I
had the job I had spent a ton of time
prepping for that first day on the job
about how I would handle it what I would
do what my approach to show running
would be and I was lucky because I had
had a good mentor the showrunner before
me was Elliott schoneman and he had a
very precise way of doing it and so I
took a lot from him and my goal in
running a show was to get people excited
about their own ideas everybody else's
ideas and really make it a fun room and
when you make it a fun room and you
value the other writers ideas great
stuff can happen
and so because I had been in the worst
of writers rooms and the worst of
writers rooms go like this where they
have eight writers and one showrunner
the showrunner wants to rewrite
everything so that all the showrunner
wants is people around to spit out stuff
and and kind of tell them how great he
is and this happens way too often
and at the end of the day no matter how
much work they do in that room
the showrunner is gonna take it home by
himself and rewrite every word and so
you have a demoralized staff I had no
interest in having the more aligned
staff I wanted other people's
contributions because in comedy that's
what makes it better you know just one
person alone can really make it as good
as a group there are exceptions this
show fleabag is apparently written by
one person and she's very talented
but who knows maybe fleabag would be
even better if she had a staff you don't
know so how long we the showrunner for
Pappas in four years okay and what was
the latest you and your group worked
your team of writers you know there
would be occasional really late nights
and for me for us a really late night
might be midnight there are rooms that
go later than that and but we always my
kind of the thing that I strove for is a
showrunner was no weekends no weekends
in the room because I had kids I had a
wife I wanted to spend time with them
and when I was doing shows even working
for other people I didn't really mind
that much working the late nights during
the week if I could get those two days
off with my family so that was that was
important would you also look at
feedback from the audience and how would
you integrate old prune was fantastic
they had come up before I even gone the
show they had this whole system now
nobody else did this at the time for the
Wednesday run-through we would read the
script on Monday run through the show on
Tuesday afternoon and then
through it again for the network on
Wednesday afternoon and when we did our
run-through we would bring in 20 people
from the universal tour in folding
chairs to watch the run-through so those
those people told us what was working
and what wasn't working
and then by Thursday night camera run
through the show was in great shape and
we were good to go on Friday night how
would they deliver that would you sort
of do a QA with him afterwards he was
all based in there laughs there's all
this time laughs it's not hey you like
this if they're laughing they like it
that's true
there's not a sympathy laugh that you
could tell they were oh no you can tell
what's going on sure having worked on
other television shows you knew you
didn't want to quote demoralize of the
other writers I wanted to make them feel
a part of the process
sure so what were you telling the fellow
writers on home improvement while you
were the showrunner well I tell them
first of all to come in with stories
because that's part of their job the
main thing in a show that I run or any
show that is run well is that nobody
from your staff should just shoot down
an idea and say that's not good that is
cardinal rule number one of working on a
television show comedy you always have a
fix and even if your fix is not the
final one or maybe not even the best one
that you're going to get to if somebody
says you know that jokes no good
that everybody's not going to last in my
room because that writer has to pitch
another joke that's their job or if they
don't like a story they need to think of
something that that they think is better
so in other words you just don't be
negative it's all you come at it to be
constructive so let's say we're two
writers and writers room and you pitch a
joke and say and then she follows down
at the end and instead if I was thinking
wow that's really bad instead of me
saying it I would
like or if that's what if okay what if
the key to words are what it yeah
because that way you're not necessarily
insulting the last person who pitched
who might be insulted because they might
say oh wait a minute mine was great but
if they've got to understand that that
I'm coming into writers room people are
gonna have a lot of different ideas and
the what-if is so much better than the
that sucks so I would trade out the bad
sucks for the worth and so then how
would the joke went out if then another
writer over here said wait what if she
does this or whatever
at what point that's the showrunner job
you decide when it's good enough when
you like it and you know you you have to
be the final work so that really what it
really is what it means to be a showroom
somebody somebody has to have the final
word and somebody's got to take the heat
when the network and the studio don't
like the show or the star doesn't like
the show so the showrunner makes the
decision and the star may say that sucks
and then you have to face the music how
are you going to fix that but that's
part of the gig did you ever get
feedback what let's suppose you wear the
final say on the joke and you thought it
was great and you were so proud and it
backfired on you and you got letters or
people who were upset you know when I
did this it was before you know Twitter
and all this stuff the letters went to
the studios I never saw the letters but
you know we would we would do a final
pass the whole room would do a final
pass on a script before it went to the
actors at the table on Monday and we
turned in a script that we thought was
great the actress today did the studio
could hated the network they anybody you
know because it's a subjective business
anybody can like or hate anything and
I've been on shows where the actors if
they read the script in advance or as
they're reading it at the moment if they
see a line they don't like they will
take it so in other words they
don't even want this line to have a
prayer of winding up to the show so they
read it in such a way to make sure you
know they don't like it and that nobody
at the table laughs so so they sabotage
it
crispin are you almost grateful that
social media that instant feedback
wasn't available or do you guess so yeah
no yeah I know
I don't need social media feedback for
pretty much anything I mean because
remember we live in a world today where
everybody is a pundit okay so you have
you know millions and millions of
experts on what the United States
government should be doing and what the
president should be doing and you know
if you think about our lives before
social media you might read an editorial
by a really experienced columnist
analyzing the situation and saying you
know here's what we should do and then
maybe the next week you'd read something
by another really well-informed person
saying you know I don't think so
now we're getting advice from every
single person who has a phone and you
know what we don't need that we we have
plenty of experience and talented people
and it's great that everybody gets a
voice and a part of the conversation but
at a certain point it becomes like white
noise and and that's why so many people
get to a point they say we're turning it
off this week or we're turning it off
forever
I'm off Facebook I don't have a personal
page anymore or whatever and and they
just get burned out on it and if you
know and I've experimented with this and
not using it for a while and I would say
and they've done scientific studies that
people get off social media are happier
so there you go
so once you knew you were going to be
the showrunner for home improvement you
did a lot of research you prepared you
show up you're now facing this room of
writers most of whom you know how are
you dealing with that and was it as you
imagined well first of all I gave them
all homework it's like kids in school
today now they have to redo reading over
the summer my assigned they had
assignments their assignments were to
come in with maybe four to six stories a
piece or three stories of peace I don't
remember what it was but everybody had
to come in with and deliver something
and so already you have just a bunch of
stuff to work with
I had stories that I brought in and all
my writers had stories so we had a lot
to talk about
and so they had stories and the other
thing that you talk about on day one
really before you even get into the
stories is the arc of the season what's
gonna happen at the beginning and the
episode one of the season and what's
gonna happen in episode 22 or 24 however
many we were doing and once you kind of
set up that general art then you get to
the stories because the arc tells you
where you want the characters to go so
the story is that these writers come in
with they're not that worked out because
first you have to sign out of your arc
and where you want your characters to go
but I'm pretty confident that all of us
came in with stories that then actually
did fit in with the arc or we could
tweak to the arc and you know that's how
we got started so you ideally you get
started with just a burst of energy and
everybody's really excited to be there
it's the first day of work people are
getting paid to be writers in television
in Hollywood and it's a privilege how do
you know you're keeping the story moving
forward was there were there times when
you thought you were doing things that
were great jokes were funny but then you
stood back and said the story isn't
moving forward well you know in
traditional multi-camera sitcom there's
always the tendency to do to make it too
many jokes and slow down the scene
because you think you're being so funny
with all the jokes people are telling
but it becomes pretty evident along the
way if people are just standing around
telling jokes and the story isn't being
served so and then if you have a staff
of good people
somebody's gonna something gonna say hey
don't we need to get to this story
points sooner and could we cut this so
that that's very common speaking of
cutting I'm thinking of let's say
Three's Company and sometimes like mr.
Roper would come in and it was just a
look he didn't have to say a word and
you already knew he was either judging
Jack Tripper or somebody how did you
know sometimes said you know what let's
just do it as a look was that when the
actor well Tim Allen you know when you
work with somebody who the audience
loves you get so many extra laughs with
looks like that so you know as a show
grows you realize who's you know a look
on a certain line you know he's going to
get a laugh so in home improvement the
thing that made that show a success Tim
Allen was a very successful comedian but
the thing that made the show a success
was coming up with a worthy adversary to
play his wife and witch who was Patricia
Richardson and we knew that if we wrote
a scene and he did something stupid and
she gave him a look the audience
especially the women were gonna go there
they were gonna love it so you know you
learn about those looks and and what
what they're gonna what they're going to
give you comedic Lee in fact we did a
whole show a little episode of home
improvement called the look and what
that was one of the writers came in with
this idea and it was based on just the
look that your wife gives you when you
act like an idiot and so this whole
thing was the episode was called the
look and it featured a very funny comic
named Blake Clark and he played the
owner of a hardware store in home
and his wife played by a very funny ex
groundling named Shirley pres Tia and he
would talk about the look that he would
get and I guess we did stuff with Tim
and his his wife at home but with Blake
and Shirley she would give him she had
one of those looks she'd give him the
look the audience would go crazy and
then he'd give the look back and Tim was
in the scene too and he'd be looking at
them giving them though giving each
other look and the last just they spread
they I mean no dialogue at all the
laughs every time the director knew when
to cut from look - look - look - look
and the and the laughter just built like
crazy was a really funny episode do you
think that's what distinguishes a lot of
new writers versus more seasoned is
knowing when to cut out some of the
jokes and to go to the looks you know it
was what distinguishes watching a show
grow because you don't know when you
start a show what what's gonna hit from
which actors so it's learning the the
whole thing it's not just what's on the
page it's what's on the stage so if the
if the actors are really gifted
physically and you start to see
audiences reacting or even in a single
camera show you can tell if somebody's
reaction is just hysterical and you know
you make a mental note of that and then
you start to use that but it usually
grows from seeing the actors work with
the material forgiveme didn't that
happen with a show that you did called
duet where two stars started out as the
main characters and then it was so that
was a whole other whole other bit of
business I mean that was duet was on the
when the Fox Network first started and
we followed married with children which
was a huge hit and we did okay it was a
pretty funny show the audience is the
the studio the network they liked the
show but they felt that the two leads
weren't as funny as these two side
characters
so it was one of these really weird
situations where the two side characters
became the lead characters of the show
and then one of the main characters
stayed in the show but one didn't it was
bizarre it was really bizarre and that
was the first sitcom first acting job
for Ellen DeGeneres she was in she was
in the spin-off of duet called
open house playing a secretary in a real
estate office oh I bet that was funny
and the other person it was between
Ellen DeGeneres and Paula Poundstone oh
and they were both hilarious how is an
episode of television structured and has
it changed over the years well it's
changed over the years because more of
the sitcoms our single camera so in the
old days really at the beginning of the
multi-camera
not the very beginning of Lucy but let's
say when I was working at Paramount and
most of those shows would have maybe six
scenes and you would and it was only two
acts today you have three acts and if
you still on a network with commercials
you have well the offices I don't know
maybe it's even more than three it'll be
three acts with a teaser and a tag so
there's tons of commercials everywhere
that of course people are you know
zipping through so in the old days you
just really wanted a great at break so
you know when you only have two acts so
an act break would kind of be a sort of
a cliffhanger where you want people to
come in after the commercial that was
the way that worked so then they started
making the running time of network shows
shorter I think when I started they were
24 minutes now they're probably under 21
minutes so there's a lot of commercial
time and they break it all up so what I
think the network's want is instead of
one reason for people to come back they
want like four or five reasons for
people to come back and most of the time
honestly
it doesn't happen because if you're
doing 21 minutes of content
how many cliffhangers you can have in 21
minutes of contact content so that's why
if you watch a network show today you'll
see seems cut off and you'll be like god
that's so annoying and and because I got
to get all these commercial breaks in
which is why people love non network
television because they can actually
take a breath and and not even have to
grab the remote to go through the
commercials sorry what is a teaser and
what is it I'm sorry
teaser usually is a scene at the
beginning which is maybe it can be
anywhere from two to two and a half
pages it's just a little quick nugget it
may not even have to be on story that is
just before the main title or before the
the first scene it's something that's
quick and pops with a big joke at the
end that that grabs the audience and a
tag is pretty much the show is over and
then they'll do maybe a one-minute scene
you know it could be after the wrap up
it's just something that might go into
the end credits so you want a big joke
at the end of that - and then it goes
into the to the end credits so this is
all stuff that doesn't need to exist it
all has to do with commercial breaks how
does a new season of a television show
began in the writers room well it's
pretty much like I said it has to do
with the arc of the arc of the season
where are the characters in at pointing
and usually they are where we left them
off at the end of last season and where
do we want to take them by the end of
the season so if you you know if you
know that the end of the season you the
characters in your show where the stars
are in a relationship and by the end of
the season they're going to break up you
have sort of the the beginning and end
and then the whole season is the
building blocks of well why are they
fighting and
you know do they get back together at
some point in the season and who else
are they dating and so but you kind of
decide where you're gonna end and then
sometimes you may decide where your
ending is going to be but you'll find so
many other interesting curves along the
way that you'll say wait a minute it's
more interesting if they're together at
the end of the season but their
relationship has changed in this way
well speaking of TV couples why do you
think duet wasn't able to last but then
you said Matt about you was similar it's
a very funny funny question because Paul
Reiser was one of the people that they
were gonna he was a possibility it's a
star and do it and I can't tell you it
may have been that they turned Paul
Reiser down for duet and then he went on
to do mad about you which was a similar
concept but he and Helen Hunt was it
were a much more dynamic couple that the
audience really followed and you know
our couple they were good actors but I
don't think the audience could be as
invested in them as the other couple
Paul Reiser also had been it was a
stand-up so he was very very funny
really so why so do you think that his
sort of star power or just sort of
burgeoning star power helps carry that
why do you think one couple was
impressed well it all has to do with the
chemistry between I mean the right has
to do with the writing and I thought our
show was well written but those two
stars had great great chemistry Helen
Hunt and Paul Reiser and the supporting
characters they the the people who
surrounded them were great
the writing was great and they had the
magic you know because every show that's
a hit you have to have some magical
element and they had it and we didn't we
did you feel that way when it ended
because I know what mad about you hadn't
do it mean when do what ended were you
as sort of you know able to see it in
this way I was able to see it I mean I
he's been a person and there's and you
know you talked earlier about stars
versus the art you know is it what's
more important to create or to be a star
I think as a person whose primary
motivation has been to create I've been
able to have a pretty realistic view of
the shows that I've worked on and how
good they are and what the problems are
and what what works and what doesn't and
I think I had a very realistic view
about the strengths and weaknesses of
duet and I felt that you know there were
things about it that were preventing it
from for being a hit writers have to
write whether they want to or not
whatever is lurking deep within their
souls has a mind of its own spewing out
words that delight us or make us cringe
in horror you said something about this
at the Bombeck Writers Workshop keynote
you did in 2014
correct you talked about that why do
writers have to write I guess it's in
you and somebody made this comment to me
the other day they said we were you know
because I've been doing novels and now
this new book and they said you know we
really admire that you're still doing
this and I said well I just do it I do
it because it's what I do and and but
I've always been the kind of person and
one of the reasons that in a way I was
happy to get away from sitcom is that I
think when I feel like I don't have
anything more to say I'll probably stop
writing but as long as you have some
idea in you that you feel is worthy then
you want to do it and in this particular
book I have one essay in this book silo
I'll hold it up one more time the way we
the way we work and in this book this
book has 41 contributors talking about
their Hollywood experiences so my
contribution I wrote one essay out of
the 40
and there are many people in this book
who are far more famous than I am but my
essay is about working in sitcoms and
having to basically kind of like put
your writers voice on hold because when
you work on somebody else's show like
home improvement that is the creator's
voice and Tim Allen's voice it's not you
so you become sort of an imitator a
mimic you've got to write this show kind
of the best way it can be written like
in a way like it's been written before
put your own little spin on it but it's
not you so I'm at the point in life of
being writer where I get to write what I
want to write and and I won't I don't
think I want to write if I don't feel I
have anything worth writing about you
had a long career in television then you
write two novels that are about sort of
anti-heroes that are questioning right
the American dream correct
why why write about that um I guess well
first of all when I wrote the first one
I didn't really know whether I was
capable of writing a novel and I just
came up with this character who was
about the same age as I was guess early
50s or 50 and he's questioning his life
and he does not want his life to go out
the way it's been going so far he's kind
of been sort of a loser for the two
first two acts of his life and he wants
the third act to be something you know
that's worthy that he could be proud of
so I I didn't really know this at the
time but I mean I knew that I was
looking to do something new my life had
been my working life had been successful
but like the main character I wanted my
next act to be something different I
didn't quite know what it was so as I
wrote this character you know the
character started off as a loser and his
problems were different than my
but as I got through the plot of the the
book the character and I shared a lot of
similar things so it was really an
amazing writing experience from that
point of view and then with cascade
falls you have it where the characters
sort of up against the the shadow of his
successful father absolutely right so
that dream also starts in Hollywood that
that it's about I was really curious
about this what happens to those people
who have a Hollywood dream and then get
involved it you know they have a
relationship because they want to have
somebody get married and then they have
kids but that dream doesn't work out so
what happens to their life when they
have to go to plan B and what happens
when they go to plan B and they're not
happy with Plan B and Plan B has made
makes them miserable but yet they've
already taken this step into marriage
and parenting how do they how do they
deal with that so you know I saw people
around me who you know they were they
thought they were gonna be really really
successful and they weren't and they
were and now they were married and now
they had kids and what were their lives
like how do you make those lives good
and and how do you be happy with who you
are so there were so many interesting
questions to explore there what do you
think it is that the people because I've
seen people that seem out really very
successful they don't think they are I
know two different people I heard say oh
yeah well we had to take our kids out of
private school and it was like this
dreadful thing it was like they had
failed in life when most people it's not
even a matter of being able to put them
in private school what do you think
people see their lives as failures
because they're not on the cover of
variety well thank you la you're always
I mean I mean it's so obvious and the
way the world is becoming the the gap
between the haves and the have-nots is
getting bigger and bigger and you know
in a city like LA which does have a lot
of problems with its public schools
and people see their friends being able
to put their kids in private schools and
they they want to do that as well and
then it becomes kind of a thing that
well now I can't do that anymore so I
must be a failure and they're not
failures they're just they're just break
it people is it okay to be you I mean
did you get to a point where you said I
want to be doing fun stuff I want to be
doing stuff that fulfills me and whether
now I can walk into a room and people
are gonna really want to perk up and
hear what I do versus me feeling
fulfilled and maybe no one's heard of it
is more important to me did you get to a
point in your life where some of that
didn't matter anymore of people of
people sort of the the outward Hollywood
success did you get to a point oh yeah
definitely it made more sense for Bruce
to be happy no absolutely and I was
forced into that situation well first of
all you know I had done well and then my
first wife passed away so I had I had to
take care of my children so that kind of
eye-opener you know that changes things
you know hurt and you get your
priorities straight in a hurry and as I
was working through that you know I had
to think about what's the next step in
my ever am I gonna go back and write and
I took time off and then when I was
ready to write again I didn't want to
write sitcoms anymore I mean I did a
couple of things a couple of pilots and
I was just he was not a fun experience
and that's when I got into the novel
ready and why did you want to do this
book because it's not a novel it's more
of a Q&A this book I wanted to do
because I got sick of sitting alone in a
room and I was alone in the room when I
did this too but the difference was I
had to work with other people I had to
get other people to agree to be in this
thing and then I had to do the work of
editing their work and it was really fun
it was really fun to do to do something
different that wasn't all about me you
know there are a lot of people who work
in Hollywood I mean people similar to to
my level
who write their own memoir for me I
would never do that because I mean my
I've had some interesting things happen
in my life especially you know with my
wife and all that stuff but I just I'm
not the kind of person who would feel
comfortable writing a 300 page memoir
about me it's not not my thing so it was
really wonderful to be able to do all
these little mini memoirs of people who
also like meet me maybe don't feel like
they want to write a whole memoir about
themselves maybe they don't have a whole
memoirs worth of stories but everybody
has a story to tell and it was great to
be able to include these people
especially the below-the-line people who
never get to talk about what they do I
have a hair stylist a makeup artist I
have an animal trainer talking about her
job and it was wonderful because these
people never get their voices heard so
it was a great project from that point
of view so you got out of being alone in
the room for a while two interviews
people did you learn anything about
yourself
not just like so and so work with this
star and this person and but I mean in
terms of did you see similarity with all
the writers and yourself yeah I mean a
lot of the writers and I kind of knew
this that all the writers have been
through certain struggles with their
shows and but you know you hear
everybody else's point of view and
everybody else is individual story and
it just it resonates for you it's not
yours necessarily but you relate to it
in a way that you go ah yeah I can see
that so it was wonderful to hear other
people's points of view
what do you think makes a great story a
great to me a great story is made by a
great character and that's just the way
I write and I'm not a I never professed
to be somebody who deals in you know
heavy-duty plot they don't write
detective novels I just don't do that so
for me you know a great novel is a great
character or a great set of characters
set of characters I think at the Brady
Bunch
I mean it was a really won main
character on that show was there it was
really more from the point of view of
all of them wasn't it yeah
okay so there wasn't like a main
protagonist right I mean but from my
writing and from what I love you know
it'll either be one character that I can
just sink my teeth into or you know it
could be a number of characters one of
my favorite books one of my favorite
writers is TC Boyle and he wrote this
book called the tortilla curtain about
Los Angeles and the two different worlds
of Los Angeles the people who live
behind gates and the immigrants who are
living in the canyons and this book was
written
I don't know 25 years ago and it just so
speaks to where we are today and so the
Mexican there there there's a Mexican
main character who's just trying to make
a living and then there are the rich
people up the hill and all of these
characters are extremely well drawn and
the situation is just it speaks to you
know where we are today it's just an
amazing book well you think about Chavez
Ravine back in the day and there's some
similarities to maybe they're not
dragging people out as they did at that
time but did it's not too far from it in
some ways to try to make me now you
wrote in one of your books about someone
that goes to work for his real estate
developer father and is sort of you know
it's this very manicured you know in in
Arizona with fresh lakes brought in the
works like that so what is it about that
sort of looking at this idyllic American
life versus that creative longing that
attracts you
um that idyllic American life was
interesting to me because it was fake so
in other words these were people trying
to build a tropical paradise in a desert
and make it look like you know
California or Disneyland or whatever it
is
and what interested me about that was
people's long that they so longed for
that type of community that even if it
was in the desert and 120 degrees all
year round they could kind of fool
themselves into thinking they were in
Florida or California or in in Hawaii
you know so that was one aspect of it as
far as the creative life that's a whole
other question I'm not sure how that
relates to that well why doesn't it work
out for he and his wife crazy in the
book yeah if you don't mind I know that
might be Sarah it's a writer a very I
wrote this guy he's a writer who just
stumping in Bella sell things we
couldn't make it work so yeah so it came
from my experience watching other
writers who weren't as fortunate as I
was trying to deal with real life and
cuz I kept thinking you know what if
that were me I mean you know I was lucky
it always takes a little bit illini I
have talent but you also have to have a
little bit of luck and if you don't how
do you live what do you do how do you
how do you come to terms with that I
know you're shopping around this is it a
television show for elevating over yeah
so how's it's been a while since you
wrote the book how a long time ago shop
it and you have someone who Jay mitat
well Jason Alexander who did the audio
book wants to do this with me as a
series and you know we're just really we
we only brought it to one place and now
we're in the process of thinking you
know where else we want to bring it and
you know he's a fantastic talent and the
thing that I love about it I mean he's
what was really interesting about the
book is that
I wrote this book and I wrote this
character and then when the book was
done I had a friend who was working with
Jason on a play and Jason and I didn't
know each other so he was on doing
Seinfeld I was doing home improvement we
were both in the top ten but we didn't
know each other but my friend was
producing a play with Jason and I called
him and I said if I put this book in an
envelope with a note saying that I was
the executive producer home improvement
I'm not some Schmo off the street would
you give him this book to read and so in
the note I wrote you know you're gonna
know by page three whether you like this
or not and so of course I didn't hear
from him for months and then three
months later I get this email I love
this I'm gonna do this and you know
we're talking about a movie versus a TV
show so now he and I are friends and
he's gonna be doing this a book event
for me even though he's not in this book
the way we work he and I are gonna be
talking about Hollywood at this book at
this place called dynasty typewriter how
do you shop around a show like what's
your process especially knowing that you
have someone like Jason Alexander who
wants to play the protagonist correct
yes so first of all you have to get the
meeting and you'll either an agent will
get the meeting of Jason knows a lot of
people sometimes you'll get the meeting
and then Jason and I will talk about how
we want to go and pitch this thing and
you know in a case like this it helps to
have somebody like Jason in the room
because absolutely he's a great presence
and you know in addition to being
quote-unquote attached he's actually in
the room so that that helps enormously
you said earlier that you in the email
to Jason or the note you'll know by page
three whether you like this or not is
that always been your rule kept by page
three of a script or novel you know the
writers voice is either for you or not I
I don't know that I have a hard and fast
rule you always want the beginning to be
too pop there's no question about that
but what I felt in terms of elevating
Overman was that this character made
itself known by page three and that he
reading this character would know right
away he know whether he liked the
writing because the writing was
certainly distinctive to the way I write
and he would know the character well
enough to know if that was something
that he felt you know intrigued him what
was your favorite interview out of your
new book my favorite I have many many
favorites that's a and and they're not
all interviews because the writers wrote
essays because the writers that's what
writers can do and people who are not
writers were not asked to write essays
they were interviews so I have favorites
you know many many favorites so gosh
there's so many there's so many great
essays in this thing I have an essay by
screenwriter named David kuhkaff who
writes about writing for Hollywood when
all they wanted was high-concept and he
explains the kind of high concept
scripts that he had to turn out and
writing one for the Olsen twins and it
was just you know these premises are
just unbelievable but this is what
people were paying for back then so he
wrote a great essay and then I had
people I have a whole chapter called the
icon which is about people who got their
starts in Hollywood who were lucky
enough to work with people who were
major stars so I had somebody who worked
with Orson Welles somebody who worked
with Martin Scorsese and somebody worked
with Lucille Ball and they talked about
their experiences working with stars
what do you think of Sunset Boulevard I
think it's a Sunset Boulevard the movie
look one of the best movies ever made
you think it's a it still holds today in
terms of not likeability but the story
and what happens and it's totally maybe
maybe the screenwriter doesn't go live
with the person but in terms of I don't
want to say desperation but that's
probably the right word yeah I mean it
happens you hear about it all the time
and listen I know about people who were
big Hollywood successes TV
who made a lot of money and they thought
it was going to go on forever they spent
it all and some of it went up their
noses and all gone and really sad
stories sure for your new book whose you
have something from JJ Abrams yes and he
writes about endings yeah okay
so in a weird way that's the power
because if you don't know and you're
writing it then that's what the audience
is feeling if it's clear to you it's
clear to the audience then you want it
to be the power and great storytelling
is going oh I'm so intrigued by how this
will turn out so do you like being in
the dark about endings to a story you're
writing whether it's pure like I like
about I like having an ending in my mind
and then as I go through having the
freedom to say you know what I think I
want to try this and come up with
something that you never thought in a
million years you would come up with and
and that that is the greatest moment
ever so I'm writing a new novel now and
I had an idea I've just finished like
the second draft I had an idea of how it
would end but there were parts of this
ending that I never could have
envisioned and as I got there it just
sort of fell into place and whether it's
good whether it's bad I cannot tell you
at this point but well I know is that I
was so pleased to find this surprising
thing available to me based on what I
had set up in the beginning so you had
it sort of a clear vision of how you
want it to be but then in but then on it
as the story unfolded it got tweaked in
different ways that were surprising to
me and hopefully you know resonate with
the audience how many hours do you spend
a day writing these days probably about
four hours minimum and then if I'm doing
well maybe a little more in the TV days
it was a lot different
when you're with your staff you're there
all day long
you could be writing for 12 hours but
you've got a lot of people around you in
a lot of different voices one of the
things that happens on TV shows is that
when you assign scripts to the staff
everybody goes off and writes their
scripts and you usually have maybe 10
days to write a script and during those
days you know I when I remembered
writing my own scripts I remember
working for 8 hours a day or you know or
more just trying to hone the script you
know it helps to have in your mind how
many pages do I want to get out today
and get them out whether they're good or
bad you know you can rewrite him get
like something down on paper you know
apparently Judd Apatow calls is the
vomit draft where you just get it down
and you don't edit yourself right away
you get it on paper because once it gets
down there trust yourself to know what
[ __ ] you know and you'll get in there
and you'll you'll rewrite it and you'll
make it better but just don't block your
mind from from getting something down so
what goals do you set for yourself for
your novel writing it tells it in prose
about three pages a day and sometimes
it'll be more sometimes it'll be it's
usually at least three are you better
the morning um you know what once you're
you're living your life and you have
people that you have to take care of and
all that stuff it gets different because
you're you're a little more flexible so
I used to which in previous years I'd
say the mornings but now there are
certain days that I have my mornings I
have things I do in the morning so I'll
start at 1:00 and I'm cool I'll go from
1 to 5 and you know try to get my stuff
done and usually I do and it works
robert towne writes in your book Bruce
that people who read scripts whether
it's actors directors producers etc
usually have three questions will this
script be any good as a movie will it
make me look good will I work again if I
do it how true is that and any thoughts
you can add well I mean it's really true
there's one essay in the book by Elliott
schoneman where he talks about his life
as a young hot writer and he had been
working on the show Maude would be
Arthur and he'd gotten to know her
husband who was this director gene Sachs
bean sacks was best friends with Walter
Matthau Jean asked Elliot to do a movie
with him Walter Matthau said yes where
the script everybody loves that they
loved it they loved it and then
Universal gives the go-ahead so it's a
go movie and then Gene saxes last movie
comes out and bombs and Walter Matthau
calls Elliot up and Walter Matthau and
gene sacks were best friends
Walter Matthau calls Elliot up and he
says do we need gene to direct the movie
and the movement was genes idea and
Elliot said well yeah I can't do it
without gene and Walter said well you
know it was your idea kid and he said no
actually it was genes idea and so he was
trying to get Elliot to throw gene off
the movie and Elliot wouldn't throw gene
under the bus because he owed a lot to
gene and then Walter Method said I can't
do the movie if gene is directing
because his last movie bombed and and
these guys were best friends so there's
Hollywood for you